-Our next guest
is a "New York Times"
best-selling author.
Her new book,
"Hiding in Plain Sight,"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
Sarah Kendzior.
How are you, Sarah?
-As well as can be expected.
How are you?
-I'm good.
I like that in your bookshel
behind you,
you're using it to very --
very smartly
promote your new book.
-Oh, yes.
Of course.
-Well, we were talking.
You obviously
had a book tour planned.
You were actually gonna be
on our show in the studio
back in -- I guess, in March
So, how has it been
having a book --
a new book out that obviousl
you worked on for years
and not being able to go out
and promote it?
-I mean, I'm sad about it.
I'm sad that I didn't get to
you know, see my readers
face-to-face.
But I'm mostly
thinking about safety,
and I don't want to put anyone
in that position.
And there's certainly people who
are having a much harder tim
in this economy and in thi
public-health crisis than me
The book itself is about the
danger of this administratio
and the erosion
of stable institutions,
not just in the present
but over the last 40 years
So, paradoxically,
this is a good time
for the book to come out.
-So, I want to talk about
the book, but real quick,
you recently tweeted the las
time you were on the show,
and, again, it was nice that
you got to see the other guests.
-Mm-hmm.
-You were backstage.
You got to meet Ice-T.
And here is the photo
that you tweeted.
And is it true
that your mother --
Your mother has this framed?
-Oh, yeah.
I gave it to her
as a Mother's Day gift.
Because I sent it to her,
and she loved it,
and then, you know,
I surprised her.
She has it on her mantel.
Just like every baby boomer,
huge Ice-T fan, "Law & Order."
Completely forgot
that she confiscated
my "Body Count" cassette
in like 1991.
So, you know...
-Well, it's a shame because,
you know,
the first guest tonight
was Ice Cube.
So I like that
there's something thematic
about the times on your show
-As long as this doesn't lea
to Vanilla Ice
the third time around, then I'
all good with this trend, so..
-So, last time you were on
you were talking about
your book,
"View from Flyover Country."
And it was a lot about,
sort of --
You had studied
autocratic regimes
and how they, you know,
have this way
of sneaking up on people.
Exactly what is happening
to the, you know,
systems they rely on.
When you obviously
wrote this book,
you couldn't have imagined
the moment we are in right now
but it does sort of predict that
if things don't change,
this is the sort of thing
we were gonna end up with,
right?
-Yeah.
I mean, I didn't predict
that I would be talking to you
during a plague
from our self-quarantine,
but in terms of malice,
in terms of kleptocracy,
in terms of the profound erosion
of institutional stability
and social trust,
this is what I expected
from the Trump administration.
Because we've had this kind of
facetious, unearned reliance
on checks and balances
that were never really there
They were not applied at the
start of his administration,
and he has spent the last
four years annihilating them
purging agencies,
packing courts,
you know, basically
stripping this country dow
and selling it for parts.
And so, yeah, here we are.
-You point out that
the media sometimes
will focus
on Trump's ineptitude,
but you think the mistake ther
is it ignores
the more sinister side of it
-Yes, absolutely.
I think that the media,
as well as many people,
are just comfortable
thinking of him as a buffoon
that stumbled
into the presidency,
like it was an accident,
but that's not true.
And as I lay out in the book
he ran or nearly ran
for president five times -
1988, 1996,
he ran in 2000,
he ran in 2012,
he ran in 2016.
And one of
his enduring strategies
has been to cover up
his crime with scandal
and to cover up his malice
with incompetence.
A lot of people are shocke
by his reaction to the pandemic,
that we haven't had
a national mourning,
that the flag hasn't even
been lowered to commemorat
the victims and the people
who tried to save them.
But that's completely in lin
with his character.
You know, when 9/11 happened
his first reaction was to sa
it made his buildings
look taller.
When the 2008
financial collapse happened,
he said that it was a good thing
for him, that he would profit.
And back in 2014,
he went on Fox News and said
that he wanted
economic collapse,
and he wanted riots
and violence in the street
because that's what makes
America great again.
-You don't hold back
in your book
as far as, like, naming names.
-No.
-And I think the way,
a lot of times,
some journalists not only fear
you know,
the shutting down of acces
for projects they may do
in the future but also,
you know, for personal safety.
Do you --
When you are specific
about people, do you ever --
do you ever fear for your safety
when you write?
-I mean, of course.
Of course I fear for my safety
And we've seen a lot of examples
of this administration
and people connected to it
threatening people.
You know, we just had
an impeachment hearing
where the ambassador to Ukrain
basically said
that Trump and his goon squa
ordered a hit on her.
That's a huge deal,
and there's a long history
of that kind of action.
You know, so, yeah,
I worry about my safety.
But I'm more worried that
the truth of this administration
and its history
isn't being told.
And so that's what, you know
I have chosen to do in this book
and through my other work.
And I don't care about access.
You know, I live in Missouri
I'm not worried about not bein
invited to a cocktail part
or whatever the hell peopl
do in D.C.
And so that's never really
been an issue for me.
And then, you know, perversely
it gives me a certain
kind of freedom.